NARRATOR: The idea of
otherworldly agents
of good and evil
influencing humans
exists in nearly every
culture throughout the world.
Philosophers, religious
scholars, and psychologists
have long debated not only
the existence of but also
the nature of these forces.
Whether we think
of light and dark
forces in metaphysical terms--
that is, out there somewhere--
or psychological terms,
there are light and dark
forces of some kind.
And respecting
that is important.
The majority of humans on
Earth and throughout history
believe that otherworldly
beings are actually agents.
They're doing things
in this world,
either directly to us or
indirectly, and that they too
are experiencing a battle
or a struggle and using us,
as humans, as agents,
as proxies, if you will,
to fight this battle.
I think when you look at
all the evidence of the UFO
and the ancient
astronaut evidence,
you're going to find behind this
the entities that were accused
of causing the
darkness, the war,
the suffering,
all of that, were,
by and large,
extraterrestrial entities.
They called them the gods in
Mesopotamia, also in Egypt.
And then that morphed into
angels and the forces of Satan.
Today, we call them
extraterrestrials.
But it's really the same thing.
NARRATOR: Mount
Helicon, Central Greece.
At the base of this mountain,
6th century BC poet Hesiod
claimed to have made
contact with the nine
muses, immortal daughters
of the god Zeus,
said to impart knowledge
and art to humans.
Hesiod composed poems under
the guidance of these muses,
including what many
consider his most
important work, the "Theogeny"
and the infamous story
of Pandora's box.
When the titan Prometheus
stole fire from the gods
and gave it to humans,
Zeus wasn't happy about it.
Zeus wanted revenge.
So what he did was
he commissioned
Hephaestus to create
Pandora, the first woman.
So he gave Pandora a pithos,
a jar, that contained
all of the evils of the world.
We call it a box.
But in Greek, it's a jar.
And she's told, don't open this.
Then, of course,
she opens it up.
And so all these evils are
released into the world.
These evil forces are
sometimes embodied by demons.
Sometimes those demons are gods.
Sometimes they are hybrid
mix of monsters and gods.
But they are the forces of
negative events in the world.
Zeus wanted to counterbalance
the fact that they have
these good things that had been
unfairly, in Zeus's opinion,
given to humans.
So it's an explanation that
lays the existence of evil
at the responsibility of
the deities, of the gods.
NARRATOR: Might this
story of Pandora's box
be describing the release of
negative beings upon the Earth
by extraterrestrials, as ancient
astronaut theorists propose?
If we look into some
of the eastern legends,
we come across beings like the
jinn, who could, on occasion,
provide goodness and help,
and on other occasions
were like demons
and could provide
all kinds of evil and
all kinds of temptation.
The jinn are really of
some alternative world.
But they're able to
pass through gateways
and come into our
world to influence us.
NARRATOR: Is it possible
that humans were not only
the creation of
extraterrestrial beings,
but also, one deliberately
fashioned to possess attributes
of both good and evil?
and if so, aren't the
forces of light and dark
in an epic struggle to
influence the path of mankind?
The gods fashioned the
body as a sort of result
that would trap
the divine sparks
or souls of the light
beings in a human form.
One begins to wonder if this
dualistic or hybrid aspect
of humanity is
sort of like a game
to these extraterrestrial gods.
Let's conflict these humans.
Let's put them on this planet.
And let's see what happens.
Humans are essentially
hybrid beings.
We are conflicted beings.
Part of us is
immaterial and light.
The other part of us
is material and dark.
And it's that constant conflict
between us that rules our lives
and defines our civilization.